Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir blicken auf die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Da ist so einiges passiert. Es ist eng, eng, eng in dieser Liga. Ach, ich freu mich auf die Sendung. Jetzt gleich hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass, Nummer 192. Und natürlich bin ich nicht alleine hier. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Aber um mich geht's hier nicht. Es geht um meine Gäste und ich freue mich sehr auf diese Runde. Zum einen Kirsten vom Weserfunk. Einem Werder Bremen-Podcast, den ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen möchte. Ed Kirste-Pinkie auf Twitter. Hallo Kirsten.
Moin.
Ja, schön hier. So alte Podcast-Legenden jetzt ja inzwischen fast schon, kann man sagen. Oder den Weserfunk gibt es jetzt schon eine ganze Weile.
Den Weserfunk gibt es schon eine ganze Weile. Wir haben jetzt gestern unsere 151. Folge aufgenommen. Wir waren so bis zum Einstieg in die 2. Liga, waren wir immer relativ unregelmäßig unterwegs. Aber wir haben uns jetzt ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt. Es sind mehr Leute da. Und jetzt machen wir jede Woche Aufnahme. Und außerdem haben wir jetzt auch noch –da sind wir ein bisschen stolz drauf –ein neues Format angefangen, was wir ab und zu mal machen, was sich mit Werder auch beschäftigt, aber nicht nur. Das ist unsere Mixed Zone. Und da haben wir die neue Aufsichtsrätin Ulrike Hiller in der ersten Folge gehabt, mit der wir über Werder und alles Mögliche gesprochen haben. Also wenn euch das interessiert, hört rein.
Sehr gut. Werde ich auch verlinken in den Show Notes. Das klingt wirklich sehr gut. Und es ist ja auch schön, dass so ein Abstieg dann für manche auch bedeutet, wir professionalisieren uns jetzt ab. Jetzt gibt es welche Sendungen? Jetzt in der zweiten Liga wollen wir es wissen. Ebenfalls wissen will es, sehr wahrscheinlich zumindest, Raphael Wiesweg von ruhr24.de, der Ed Raphael Wiesweg auf Twitter. Ihr habt ihn hier auch schon im Rasenfunk schon mal hören können. Er ist Schalke-Experte. Hast du dich auch professionalisiert nach dem Abstieg?
Nein, ich freue mich ja hier in so einer illustren Runde dabei sein zu dürfen. Ich bin genauso semi-professionell wie vorher.
Ja, das sagst du jetzt so. Aber lasst mal bevor wir, wir wollen heute wieder über ein paar Vereine sprechen. Wir ergänzen damit quasi die letzte Sendung. Ihr kennt das inzwischen aus den Zweitliga-Kurzpässen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und wir legen natürlich zwei Schwerpunkte auf Schalke und auf Werder. Aber bevor wir jetzt durch die Vereine und die Liga durchgehen, sag mal, Kirsten, wie war es denn jetzt so, das erste halbe Jahr zweite Liga für dich? Denn der letzte Abstieg, den hast du ja nicht mehr miterlebt.
Den habe ich tatsächlich noch miterlebt.
Den hast du noch.
Aber ich habe ihn tatsächlich noch nicht so richtig ganz miterlebt. Den Aufstieg habe ich miterlebt und die erste Saison nach dem Aufstieg.
Und wie deckt sich das jetzt, was du erleben konntest in dieser zweiten Liga mit dem von damals?
Da war ich fünf. Da kann ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz viel zu sagen. Aber so jetzt, also ich merke so, ich bin jetzt auch in der zweiten Liga angekommen. Es macht mir tatsächlich fast mehr Spaß als die erste Liga zurzeit.
War das auch schon unter Markus Anfang so, ohne jetzt zu sehr vorzugreifen, oder ist das jetzt nicht neu?
Ja, also das habe ich relativ schnell gemerkt. Also es ist halt spannender in der zweiten Liga, weil da doch irgendwie immer noch jeder jeden schlagen kann. Es ist niemand, der so bayernmäßig davonrennt. Du hast halt keine RB Leipzig und Hoffenheims dabei. Also das ist halt alles irgendwie schon eine richtig lustige Sache. Also das ist halt, man macht halt fast jedes Wochenende ein Spiel gegen irgendeinen alten Traditionsverein.
Ja, okay, das ist ein guter Punkt. Raphael, wie ist für dich die zweite Liga? Wie fühlt sich es an?
Ja, er ist immer genau so wie erwartet. Ich meine, jetzt hat zwar Pauli nach der Hinrunde ein bisschen Vorsprung, aber extrem ausgeglichen und du hast so gefühlt, vor jedem Wochenende überhaupt gar keinen blassen Schimmer, wie die nächste Partie ausgeht. Da hatten wir auch schon im Laufe der Rundenhinrunde so einige krasse Beispiele. Von daher eigentlich genauso wie erwartet. Ziemlich eng, keiner ist so der glasklare Favorit. Ja, von daher, ich kann mich da Kirstens Meinung anschließen. Es ist auf jeden Fall unterhaltsamer im Sinne von spannender, weil du nicht automatisch weißt, wer oben und wer unten mitspielen wird. Auch wenn sich das vielleicht voll und sonderlich immer so ein bisschen herauskristallisiert. Dass man dann denkt, ja, die vermeintlich größeren Vereine eher oben, die aufsteigern vielleicht eher unten. Das sieht ja im Moment auch so aus. Aber es ist wesentlich ausglichener und ja, kann man das so sagen, ein bisschen mehr wie der Fußball sozusagen. Ein bisschen mehr Spannung und Liebe dabei.
Aber jetzt ist ja so das große Schreckgespenst immer. Ich will jetzt nicht dem Verein zu nahe treten, aber Sandhausen gilt ja immer als das Synonym für die 2. Liga. Wie ist es denn dann jetzt, Kirsten, gegen Sandhausen zu spielen und in Sandhausen zu spielen? Weiß gar nicht, ob ihr da auswärts oder zu Hause gespielt habt in der Hin-Serie.
Da haben wir tatsächlich auswärts gespielt. Ja gut, Sandhausen ist jetzt halt nicht so die Megakulisse, aber es ist halt auch mal lustig. Also jetzt ganz ehrlich, ich habe mich halt geärgert, dass da, glaube ich, als wir gegen Sandhausen gespielt haben, waren noch keine Gäste-Fans zugelassen. Was ärgerlich ist, weil das um die Ecke von meiner Tante ist, das hätte man super verbinden können. Aber ja, nein, aber ich finde das jetzt auch gar nicht schlimm. Also ich finde das eigentlich auch recht spannend. Man lernt einfach mal wieder neue Mannschaften kennen. Und ich meine, Sandhausen ist ja jetzt irgendwie schon so ein Stapel in der 2. Liga geworden, über den halt alle immer dann sagen, so, wenn du abstiegst, musst du gegen Sandhausen spielen. Aber ich muss jetzt sagen, so schlimm habe ich das jetzt nicht empfunden.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht für alle Beteiligten. Raphael, wie war deine Sandhausenerfahrung bisher? Oder jetzt nicht nur auf Sandhausen bezogen?
Wenn ich es jetzt nur auf Sandhausen beziehe, dann erinnere ich mich schon noch gut daran zurück, weil Schalke ja erst kurz vor der Winterpause noch gegen Sandhausen gespielt hat. Und das waren schon krasse Unterschiede von der Qualität. Also ich habe gerade gesagt, dass man das vielleicht nicht unbedingt vorher so erwarten konnte. Wie spielen wir Schalke-Sandhausen? Das war schon deutlich. Am Ende ging es 5 zu 2 aus. Es ist natürlich schon irgendwo ein bisschen komisch, unabhängig auch von Sandhausen, wenn der Stadionsprecher mal sagt, ja, und wir begrüßen auch die 50 Gäste-Fans, die mitgereist sind. Ich meine, wir klopfen auf Holzteuterteu. Es sind Gäste-Fans auch mal zwischendurch da gewesen, weil sie durften. Sieht im Moment danach aus, dass es in der Rückrunde eher nicht mehr der Fall sein wird. Aber das sind so Kleinigkeiten, die einem dann natürlich schon auffallen. Wenn es jetzt nicht gerade gegen HSV oder Dynamo Dresden geht, dann bricht da schon ganz schön was weg. Und die Qualität insgesamt ist einfach schon krass eine andere. Also das fällt sicherlich am meisten auf. Das ist schon ein großes Gefälle, wie ich finde zur 1. Liga.
Und guckt man das dann auch gerne an? Also jetzt in der ersten Saison hat das natürlich einen Neuigkeitsfaktor. Es könnte ja sein, dass da noch weitere Zweitligasaisons kommen. Also Raphael, kannst du Zweitligafußball genauso gerne gucken wie den aus der 1.
Also, da habe ich vorher gerne Schalke in der 1.
Liga geguckt.
Das ist ein bisschen gemein, was ich jetzt sage. Aber es war ja schon vor dem Abstieg auch nicht unbedingt immer so das Gelbe vom Einwasser. Schalke hat in der 1. Liga gezeigt und in der 2. Liga. Ja, es ist schon ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftiger. Ich weiß nicht, ob tatsächlich vielleicht in einem zweiten, dritten oder vierten Jahr alle Schalke hoffen, dass das natürlich nicht der Fall sein wird. Dass man sich da aber ein bisschen mehr dran gewöhnt. Aber ich stimme dir schon zu, das habe ich jetzt aus der Frage rausgehört, dass es ein bisschen schon schwieriger ist, sich erst mal dran zu gewöhnen. Es ist schon langsamer, wenn die Spieler sich drehen. Das dauert alles ein bisschen länger. Der ein oder andere Spieler denkt vielleicht auch vom Kopf her nicht so schnell mit, wenn es um Umschaltsituationen geht. Von daher gibt es da schon einige Unterschiede. Und du denkst dir manchmal so, wenn du am Sonntagmittag dann halt zum Stadion fährst für Schalke, Sandhausen, dass dann vielleicht unter der Woche vor ein paar Jahren Schalke gegen Real Madrid schon ein bisschen mehr was hatte?
Das wird gerechnet, ja. Der Biorhythmus muss ich ja auch erstmal umstellen. Der Biorhythmus eines Erstliga-Fans beginnt ja um 15.30 Uhr. Das trifft mich immer noch manchmal, wenn ich die Benachrichtigung auf dem Handy bekomme. Ach ja, stimmt, zweite Liga geht ja schon wieder los. Wahnsinn, bin doch gar nicht im Fußball-Modus eigentlich angekommen. Kirsten, wie findest du das so, wenn du so das größere Bild weg von Werder ziehst? Wie fühlt sich da die zweite Liga für dich an?
Also ich habe vorher schon immer so ein bisschen zweite Liga mitverfolgt. Gerade als Covid los war und wir alle nicht in den Stadion gehen durften und wir dann halt, also diese, dann man einfach auch Zeit hatte, alles zu gucken. Und da habe ich halt auch schon ein bisschen mehr angefangen, zweite Liga zu gucken. Und ich, also ja spielerisch ist da schon ein Unterschied, aber ich finde, das ist halt einfach ein bisschen kämpferischer teilweise. Und ich finde die Spiele auch echt teilweise spannend. Das ist jetzt nichts aus dem Bilderbuch oder aus dem Lehrbuch, aber es ist halt echt, zum größten Teil sind da echt wirklich spannende Spiele mit bei, die Spaß machen. Und das ist halt in der Bundesliga, dann guckst du halt Bayern gegen Fürth und dann ist halt …Was willst du damit andeuten?
Kick dich nicht Bayern gegen Fürth, das ist doch ein Klassiker.
Fürth kickt mich schon, aber Bayern halt nicht so. Es ist halt, sagen wir so, es ist jetzt nicht so mit Riesenspannung behaftet.
Okay, also ich stelle fest als vorläufiges Fazit, ihr beide habt den Abstieg eurer Vereine, in Anführungszeichen, eurer Vereine gut verdaut und es ist dann nicht ganz so schlimm, wie man sich das vielleicht aus der ersten Liga kommend vorstellt. Dann lasst mal ein bisschen näher reingucken, wir wollen heute ein paar Vereine näher beleuchten. Unter anderem den FC St. Pauli und Raphael, du hast es schon gesagt, die sind so die einzigen, die so ein bisschen ein Pölsterchen sich erarbeitet haben bzw. sich erarbeitet hatten. Denn jetzt tatsächlich gab es eine Niederlage für St. Pauli bei Heulstein Kiel auch noch sehr deutlich ausgerechnet in Kiel. Natürlich 0 zu 3 hat St. Pauli verloren. War das jetzt ein einmaliger Dämpfer? Wie kann man diese Niederlage erklären? Wie gefällt dir St. Pauli generell?
Ja, ich muss erstmal –du hast vollkommen recht –Pölsterchen ist ein bisschen dahingeschmolzen und ich wollte auch den Linien da gar nicht zu nahe drehen, weil die sind ja auch ziemlich dicht jetzt bei Pauli dran und spielen übrigens –Kirsten hat es gerade gesagt –wegen Spannung und so übrigens auch einen feinen Ball, aber vielleicht kommen wir da gleich auch noch zu. Pauli gefällt mir total gut, sehr geradlinig, lässt sich auch schön anschauen und umso überraschter war ich tatsächlich auch von dieser deutlichen Pleite. Grundsätzlich kannst du auch schon in Kiel verlieren. Schalke hat da sehr deutlich gewonnen und weiß wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht heute, wie sie das geschafft haben. Aber das deckt ja so ein bisschen die These von mir, dass du einfach vor dem Spieltag nicht weißt, wie es ausgeht. Und ich würde behaupten, dass viele jetzt gedacht haben, Pauli, die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich schon länger oben bleiben, die sind dann nicht so schnell wieder wegzukriegen. Und dann folgt da plötzlich so eine sehr deutliche Niederlage. Das hat mich schon dann sehr überrascht, damit habe ich nicht gerechnet. Nichtsdestotrotz habe ich das Gefühl, weil man ja auch so eine Entwicklung bei St. Pauli sieht. Die Hinrunde der vergangenen Song war ja sehr schlecht und dafür die Rückrunde sehr gut. Und sie haben offenbar daran angeknüpft. Also man sieht da eine tolle Entwicklung. Und ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich ja der Stadtteil der Verein sowieso bei sehr vielen Teilen Deutschlands sowieso sehr sympathisch und beliebt ist. Und die stehen meiner Meinung nach mitzurecht oben. Ob jetzt erster oder unter den ersten fünf. Aber das hat sich Pauli definitiv verdient und das hat der Schalke auch zu spüren bekommen im direkten Duell, da Schalke zu spät aufgewacht und da hat Pauli nicht unverdehnt knapp gewonnen.
Man merkt, dass du nur erst ein halbes Jahr in der 2. Liga bist. Im Millantoren wärst du schon viel mal verbessert worden. Denen ist wichtig, dass es Sankt Pauli ist. Aber wir wissen, wir alle wissen, wer gemeint ist. Ich bin hier nicht so streng. Es ist mir nur aufgefallen, ich habe zu viel Millantoren gehört. Da wird man halt immer korrigiert. Und jetzt habe ich es selber im Kopf. Sie haben es geschafft, mich zu natschen. Kirsten, wie blickst du auf Sankt Pauli?
Also Werder und Sankt Pauli verbinden ja sehr viel. Zumindest die Einstellung zum HSV gegenüber zum Beispiel. Aber da gibt es ja auch, die Ultras sind untereinander offiziell befreundet. Also das ist schon große Liebe. Für mich war es dann auch, als die im Weserstadion waren, so ein bisschen das Fest der Liebe, was mit einem sehr fest der Liebe-mäßigen 2 zu 2 ausgegangen ist. Was uns wenig geholfen hat, aber der Stimmung nach dem Spiel ganz gut angetan hat. Also ich mag Sankt Pauli und ich glaube auch einfach so, die haben glaube ich auch im Sommer gar nicht so viel vom Kader verloren, vom Stammkader. Und das merkt man halt jetzt auch. Also die sind eingespielt, das ist Funster wie Hummel. Und die sind jetzt erstmal durchmarschiert. Jetzt gleicht sich das so ein bisschen an. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass so die anderen Mannschaften langsam jetzt in der Saison angekommen sind und sich so ein bisschen eingespielt haben. Und dass es dann deshalb dieses Durchmarschieren wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwerer sein wird jetzt für Sankt Pauli. Aber ich glaube, die werden beim Aufstiegen sehr, sehr großes Wort dann am Ende mitsprechen.
Also ist das jetzt nicht die Ankündigung des Tiefstes, das jede Mannschaft halt mal hat und das Sankt Pauli jetzt irgendwie noch zu entheilen in diesem Kalenderjahr hat. Und dann kann man es aber so nicht weiterziehen, glaubst du nicht?
Also es kann gut sein, dass sie noch zwei, drei Spiele haben, wo sie jetzt nicht so ganz super aussehen. Aber da sie ja dann doch sich einen gewissen Vorsprung erarbeitet haben, ist das jetzt glaube ich nicht so tragend, um nicht weiter um den Aufstieg mitspielen zu können, wenn sie sich dann wieder fangen. Und ich glaube, die werden sich auch wieder fangen, weil das scheint da echt so gerade alles aus einem Guss zu funktionieren.
Ja, sehr offensiv starke Mannschaft. Außermann spielt eben in Kiel zweitmeisten Tore der Liga erzielt. Und aktuell eben, weil ihr es beide schon angesprochen habt, der Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz beträgt sechs Punkte. Also das ist das Polster, da darf man nicht mal vom Polsterchen sprechen, das St. Pauli da hat. Dahinter allerdings, nur ein Punkt dahinter, Raphael, liegt dann eben Darmstadt. Und du hast ja Darmstadt auch schon kurz angesprochen. Die wiederum haben den besten Sturm der Liga, 41 Tore schon erzielt, haben jetzt auch die letzten zwei Spiele gewinnen können, damit auch den Ausrutscher von St. Pauli nutzen können. Was macht denn deiner Meinung nach Darmstadt besser als andere Zweitligisten aktuell?
Boah, gute Frage. Beim 4-2-Sieg auf Schalke, da ging er, obwohl Schalke sehr früh in Führung ging, durch ein Eigentor. Und Darmstadt hat sehr gradlinig gespielt. Das war eigentlich so spektakulär. Haben aber vorne tolle Stürmer, was sie auch schon in den Spielen zuvor geschafft haben. Unter anderem, ich glaube, es war Sandhausen 6-1 gewonnen. Es gab mal nicht noch ein Spiel von Darmstadt, wo sie sechs Tore erzielt haben, auf Schalke 4. Das zeigt, dass es keine Eintagsfliege war. Das wirkte einfach sehr stabil und sehr beeindruckend. Da bin ich zum Beispiel aber so gespannt, ob Darmstadt 98 es halten kann über die Saison hinaus. Ich traue es zum Beispiel jetzt eher Pauli zu. Kirsten hat es gesagt, die können sich jetzt vielleicht mal noch zwei, drei, vier Ausrutscher erlauben, weil die Teams hinter Sankt Pauli werden ja auch nicht jedes Spiel gewinnen. Bei Darmstadt 98 bin ich mir ein bisschen unsicher, weil es dann doch schon ziemlich hoch herging, teilweise in beide Richtungen. Aber für mich definitiv eigentlich der Verein mit dem höchsten Unterhaltungswert in der Hinrunde.
Ja, und vielleicht haben Sie so als das den Trumpf im Armel, dass Sie zwei Trümpfe haben, Kirsten. Du bist die offensivstärkste Mannschaft der Liga nach Toren und hast aber nicht nur einen Stürmer, der viel trifft, sondern du hast zwei davon, Tietz und Pfeiffer, jeweils zwölf Tore jetzt nach diesen 18 Spielen bisher. Das senkt vielleicht auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du, weil jemand mal eine Flaute hat, das nicht mehr so aufs Feld bringst, offensiv stark zu sein.
Das ist möglich, aber wir haben ja auch bei Werder gesehen, wenn du zwei ziemlich starke Stürmer hast und einer eine fundamentale Lebenskrise auf dem Platz auslebt, dass das dann mit dem anderen auch nicht so gut klappt. Weil meistens bedienen die sich ja auch gegenseitig oder laufen sich gegenseitig den Platz frei. Also das ist halt immer so eine Sache. Da muss man immer gucken, wie weit dann einer von denen auch alleine funktioniert, wenn der andere eine Lebenskrise hat auf dem Platz.
Du musst, glaube ich, für alle Nicht-Werder-Fans aufdecken, wer die Lebenskrise hatte. Ich habe den Seufzer schon gehört, bevor du ihn überhaupt ausgesprochen hast. Aber wir kommen ja gleich noch zu Werder. Was ist so generell dein Eindruck von Darmstadt? Wir haben da auch im Kurzpass länger drüber gesprochen, dass es da Lieberknecht durchaus geschafft hat, zum einen wieder ganz gutes Wielgefühl zu erzeugen, aber auch vom Spielstil her Dinge zu verändern. Also man spielt zwar viele lange Pässe, aber mit einer sehr guten Passquote inzwischen. Man hat auch andere Wege nach vorne. Und schafft es eben dann überdurchschnittlich oft, Tore zu erzielen, was ja erstmal nicht so schlecht ist, wenn man aufsteigen will.
Dass eigentlich immer das beste Tore schießen soll, helfen, habe ich gehört. Aber ich denke, die Darmstädter, nachdem sie ja dann im Juni alle sehr böse waren, weil Werder Bremen-Markus Anfang ihn nehmen wollte und genommen hat, denke ich, sollten jetzt langsam mal Dankesbriefe nach Bremen schicken, dass wir ihnen dieses Problem genommen haben. Und dass das nicht noch Unruhe in den Laden da gebracht hat. Also ich finde, die spielen schönen Fußball. Das haben wir ja auch zu spüren gekriegt. Und wie gesagt, das ist super spannend. Ich würde jetzt, außer St. Pauli, würde ich einfach sagen, ich wüsste keinen, wo ich jetzt direkt sagen würde, die steigen auf. Bei St. Pauli bin ich mir relativ sicher. Einfach auch allein, weil ich das relativ lustig finden würde, wenn St. Pauli aufsteigt und der HSV nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich weniger überraschend, wenn ich mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenke. Was Darmstadt sicherlich auch hilft, ist die Standarts-Stärke, 2. beste Mannschaft hinter Regensburg, die da in der komplett eigenen Liga spielen, mit 14 nach Standard-Situation erzierten Toren. 2. beste Mannschaft nach Standards ist Darmstadt. Gemeinsam mit dem KSC und Hansa Rostock bei 9 Toren liegen die jeweils erzielt aus Standards. Also Darmstadt 35 Punkte, dann haben wir den HSV mit 30 Punkten. Und damit eröffnet sich ein sehr, sehr enges oberes Drittel der Tabelle. Nämlich zwischen Rang 3, dem HSV, und Rang 9, dem SC Paderborn, liegen 3 Punkte. Wir haben HSV 30, Schalke 30, Nürnberg 30, Heidenheim 30, Werder 29, Jan Regensburg 28 und Paderborn 27. Also alles unglaublich eng. Das heißt, Raphael, wir können uns jetzt für das Folgende kaum so ein bisschen an den Tabellenplätzen aufhängen, sondern müssen eher auf Dinge wie Form und generellen Eindruck gucken. Und landen damit tatsächlich auch schon, was ja positiv ist, beim FC Schalke 04, der eben aktuell mit 30 Punkten punktgleich mit dem HSV ist. In der kurzfristigen Abrechnung ist es jetzt der 4. Tabellenplatz, aber wie gesagt, ist alles sehr, sehr eng beisammen. Fass mal diese 18 Spiele von Schalke zusammen. Welche Entwicklung hat denn der Verein genommen, dass man jetzt ja da einfach deutlich mit drin ist in der Frage um den Aufstieg?
Boah, ja, Entwicklung, das ist eine gute Frage. Also vielleicht vorweg erstmal die Verantwortlichen hatten sich vorgenommen, nach der Hinrunde in der Nähe der Aufstiegsplätze sein zu wollen. Und da lässt sich ja definitiv festhalten, dass es ihnen jetzt gelungen. Nach 17, bzw. nicht nur nach der Hinrunde, sondern nach 18 Spielen. Und der Start, der war dann erstmal holprig. Schalke hat ja den Auftakt gegen den HSV verloren. Da lässt sich dann aber eigentlich auch eine wunderbare Parallele ziehen zu der Entwicklung. Ich glaube, damals hatte Schalke nur 27 Prozent Ballbesitz in dem Heimspiel gegen den HSV, hat 1-3 verloren. Und jetzt war eigentlich Schalke drauf und dran, am 18. Spieltag in Hamburg zu gewinnen. Oder hat auf jeden Fall einen mehr als nur verdienten Punkt ergattert. Hatte mindestens gleich so viel Ballbesitz und ich glaube einen Saisonrekord, was die Torschüsse auch angeht. Und da jetzt mal so einen ganz großen Schritt zum Mann zwischen dem 1. und 18. Spieltag. Und dazwischen hattest du sehr starke Schwankungen. Ich erinnere mich sehr gut noch an die 1-4-Klatsche in Regensburg. Die hast du ja gerade schon erwähnt, Jan Regensburg mit der Standardstärke. Das war schon heftig zu dem Zeitpunkt. Er war ja in Regensburg auch ziemlich souverän Tabellenführer. Da kann man ja jetzt auch gut dran erkennen, was aber passieren kann, wenn man nur so ein bisschen nachlässt. Und dann hatte Schalke eine sehr erfolgreiche Phase mit den Siegen in Rostock, gegen Ingolstadt, in Hannover, gegen Dresden. Das waren alles zu Null Siege. Und dann kamen wieder aber die Dempfer. Pokal aus bei 1860 München. Auch Niederlage beim FC Heidenheim. Das war dieses Nebelspiel, wo selbst die Zuschauer kommen, was erkannt haben. Und dann auch diese heftige Klatsche, will ich es schon fast nennen, gegen Darmstadt mit diesem 2 zu 4. Und es gibt sicherlich, ich will jetzt gar nicht jedes Spiel aufzählen, aber sehr unterhaltsame Spiele. Kirsten wird sicherlich auch sehr gut und sich noch an das 1 zu 1 in Bremen erinnern können. Das ist vielleicht noch mal ein Thema für sich. Und dann hat jetzt eigentlich zum Abschluss das 4-1 gegen Nürnberg und 1 zu 1 in Hamburg Schalke noch mal Auftrieb gegeben und auch Trainer Dimitrios Gramotzes gestärkt. Und ich finde schon persönlich, dass dadurch eine sehr gute Entwicklung zu erkennen ist, unabhängig jetzt von der reinen Tabellenposition. Schalke ist nicht nur in der Nähe der Ausstiegsplätze, sondern hat sicherlich nicht alles, aber auch einiges richtig gemacht und ist auch nicht umsonst, glaube ich, die Mannschaft, die in der letzten Viertelstunde die meisten Tore erzielt. Also die Grundvoraussetzungen stimmen zumindest schon einmal.
Wer sich nicht mehr an dieses Werder-Auswärtsspiel erinnert, da war der Schiedsrichter ein Thema. Da gab es einen Strafstoß in der Nachspielzeit. Ich weiß gar nicht, in welcher Minute genau.
In der allerletzten.
In der aller, allerletzten. Und wollen wir über diesen Elfmeter noch mal reden oder sparen?
Ich glaube, das war 1998, 1999. Ich glaube, in der Vierneunzeste. Sonst hat ja ein bisschen gedauert.
Ewig gedauert.
Es war vielleicht keine Sternstunde des Videoassistenten und des Videobeweises generell. Vielleicht können wir uns darauf einigen. Oder Kirst, möchtest du da widersprechen?
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe dieses Spiel in einem Irish-Pub mit schlechtem Essen in Nürnberg gesehen, weil in dem Wochenende meine beste Freundin geheiratet hat. Neben uns am Tisch, da sind Bayern-Fans, die diesen Elfmeter auch für völlig unrechten zielten. Die waren dann aber ruhig, als sie uns fragten, ob der Videoschiedsrichter blind ist. Dann habe ich auf ein Halbfinale im Weserstadion, im DFB-Pokal Werder gegen Bayern hin gewesen, habe Kingsley Coman gesagt und dann etwas weiter entfernt auf ein Halbfinale im DFB-Pokal in München hin gewesen und Arturo Vidal gesagt. Dann war da auch Ruhe. Wir haben so viel Scheiße fressen müssen vom Videoschiedsrichter in entscheidenden Situationen. Da nehme ich auch meine Fehlentscheidung.
Ja, das sei dir auch wirklich unbenommen. Ich wollte nur den Kontext für dieses Spiel aufmachen. Aber dann lass mal auf Schalke zurückkommen. Raphael, über Werder reden wir ja gleich noch länger. Da können wir wegen mir auch nochmal alle Schiedsrichterentscheidungen aufdröseln. Raphael, du hast jetzt schon Demetrios Gramozis genannt. Den haben ja auch Erstliga-Fans in der Rückrunde der letzten Saison noch erleben können. Und er war ja gefühlt Variante Nummer 40, wie man jetzt versuchen will, Schalke auf die 2. Liga auch letztlich vorzubereiten. Es ging ja dann gar nicht mehr so unbedingt um den Klassenerhalt als Gramozis kam. Was hat er denn verändert auf Schalke? Und hast du den Eindruck, dass das erfolgreich ist oder sein könnte?
Ich fange mal vielleicht mit dem letzten Teil an. Ich glaube, dass es erfolgreich sein kann, mit dem, wie Gramozis seine Sicht der Dinge hat auf die 2. Bundesliga. Dass es dann nun mal einfach auf andere Dinge auch ankommt als in der 1. Liga. Weil ich glaube, wir erinnern uns wahrscheinlich alle drei kaum an irgendeinen Club, der mal durch die 2. Liga-Problemos marschiert ist in all den letzten Jahren. Und da kommt es da vielleicht ein bisschen mehr auf kämpferische Aspekte und wirklich totale Fitness an. Und sicherlich auch gute Standardsituationen als vielleicht sehr viele gute spielerische Lösungen. Die gibt es oder gab es zumindest nämlich sehr oft oder sehr lange unter ihm nicht, auch nicht in der 2. Liga. Was man so hört, wie er es auch in Darmstadt gemacht hat, lässt mich ein bisschen positiv gestimmt in die nächsten Monate blicken, weil da hieß es auch, da hat er erst mal sich um die Basics gekümmert, um die Fitness, um eine stabile Defensive, ehe er sich noch vermehrt der Offensive gewidmet hat. Und das ist eigentlich auch sehr gut auf Schalke in den vergangenen Monaten erkennen zu gewesen. Wir erinnern uns wahrscheinlich alle an die letzten Wochen in der 1. Liga. Da hatte Schalke wirklich unfassbar riesige Fitnessprobleme. Die Spieler sind ja in den letzten 20 Minuten vor Krämpfen in den Waren einfach zusammengeklappt auf dem Feld. Da ging ja wirklich gar nichts mehr. Da konnte dann Gramozis einfach auch nicht mehr viel bewegen. Und ich habe es gerade schon einmal kurz gesagt, jetzt ist Schalke vielleicht sogar so fit wie kein anderes 2. Liga-Team. Sie erzielen die meisten Tore in der letzten Viertelstunde aller Clubs. Und das spricht ja schon zumindest erstmal dafür, dass das Team sehr, sehr fit ist. Die Standardsituation oder grundsätzlich Flanken über Auweian, Abnehmer, Terode, vielleicht sprechen wir da gleich auch noch ein bisschen genauer drüber, das funktioniert auch. Also er hat schon auch einfach erkannt, wo die Stärken liegen und warum sollst du es dann nicht einfach auch nutzen, diese Stärken? Ja, und ansonsten muss aber trotzdem auch noch ein weiterer Schritt kommen. Und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, jetzt ist nur die Frage, ob du das jetzt bestätigen könnt, dann in den restlichen 16 Rückrundenspielen, dass diese Spiele gegen Nürnberg und Hamburg schon eine gute Richtung eingeschlagen haben, was das Spielerische angeht, was das Offensive angeht, ein bisschen mitreißend. Das hängt meiner Meinung nach aber auch ein bisschen damit zusammen. Vielleicht wird auch Gramozis zu seinem Glück gezogen, dass einige Spieler vorne für die Offensive ausgefallen sind und Schalke dann ein bisschen anders ausgerichtet war, zumindest personell. Von daher sehr, sehr spannend, aber unumstritten ist er definitiv. Nicht, auch wenn jetzt seine Position gestärkt wurde, aber er war ja auch nicht unumstritten, als der Abstieg feststand. Sonst hätte ja auch Rufen Schröder nicht versucht, Baum ja doch zu kriegen, bevor er bei Köln unterschreibt. Das war ja dann schon so ein erstes Zeichen dafür, dass er vielleicht auch Gramozis nicht zu 100 Prozent tatsächlich den direkten Wiederausstieg zutraut.
Wenn wir sehen, was Steffen Baumgart aus Anthony Modest gemacht hat, dann hätte man sich das mit Simon Terode so eigentlich in der 2. Liga zumindest genau auch vorstellen können. Aber jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, in den letzten Spielen, also 4 zu 1 in Nürnberg, zu Hause gegen Nürnberg, Entschuldigung, und 1 zu 1 in Hamburg, da wurden ein paar Dinge verändert, weil Spiele ausgefallen sind. Was hat sich denn da verändert?
Ja, also erst einmal hat sich vor allem, das war schon gegen Nürnberg der Fall, durfte Dacoit Zhurninoff ganz vorne mal mit Spielen ausgeliehen, vom VfB Stuttgart, sicherlich auch sehr vielseitig einsetzbarer Spieler. Er durfte oder vielmehr musste aber in den ersten Spielen als offensiver Rechtsverteidiger auflaufen. Schalke spielt er mit einer 5er-Abwehrkette. Und was bei Thomas Auwian auf der linken Seite extrem gut klappt, ich denke, wir können ihn sicherlich zu einem der besten Spieler in der Hinrunde auch dadurch ausküren, funktioniert auf der rechten Seite bei Schalke halt überhaupt nicht. Und auch wenn Zhurninoff ein sehr flexibel einsetzbarer Spieler ist, hat er seine Stärken in der Offensive. Und er ist ein ziemlicher Freigeist auch, und das hat man gegen Nürnberg sehr gut gesehen. Also er hat zum Beispiel davon profitiert, dass dann Simon Therode und Marius Bülter gleichzeitig ausgefallen sind. Hätte ich das vor zwei, drei Monaten gesagt, hätte ich mir wahrscheinlich selber nicht geglaubt, dass es auch mal von Vorteil sein kann. Und so können wir es eigentlich auch noch weiter fortführen. Denn Danny Latza, gebürtiger Gelsenkirchener, als Führungsfigur geholt, hat sich ja schwer verletzt direkt am ersten Spieltag. Ist dann vor ein paar Wochen wiedergekommen, konnte dann aber auch nicht so recht überzeugen, war dann also eher mehr Risiko oder Belastung, in Anführungsstrichen, als eine Hilfe. Ist jetzt auch wieder ausgefallen, fällt auch bis Anfang des Jahres aus. Und Dominik Drexler auch neu geholt, sowieso, ich glaube, 99 Prozent der Spieler im Kader, ist viel auch auf Außen ausgewichen, sehr kämpferischer Typ, aber hatte meiner Meinung nach zu viele krasse Schwankungen in seinen Leistungen. Und jetzt hat Rodrigo Salazar, der sich auch übrigens toll entwickelt hat, wenn wir über Entwicklung sprechen, bei Schalke, mit Blendi Idrissi, einen Kicker neben sich, der seine Rolle einfach auch nochmal auf dieser offensiven 8. oder 10. Position schon fast interpretiert. Und so gefühlt, würde ich sagen, wirbelt Schalke viel mehr in der Offensive und hat viel mehr Optionen und ist vielleicht sogar noch weniger ausrechenbar. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass das schon geholfen hat. Die Frage wird dann sein, wie es halt sein wird, wenn Therode zurück ist, wenn wieder Latza und Drexler zurück sind, weil Graumozis auch kurz vor der Rückkehr, vor der ersten Rückkehr von Latza gesagt hat, wenn mein Kapitän fit ist und wenigstens 60 Minuten spielen kann, dann spielt er auch. Also eine Einsatzgarantie gegeben. Von daher bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, welche Lehren Graumozis jetzt aus den letzten Wochen in diesem Jahr zieht.
Da waren jetzt wirklich viele Namen mit dabei, bei denen ich vermute, dass eben Menschen, die die 2. Liga der Männer nicht näher verfolgen, da auch gar nicht so viel zu sagen können. Also Idrissi zum Beispiel, John Linouf hat man immerhin schon mal gehört, glaube ich. Salazar natürlich sowieso. Ovejan haben wir hier auch schon angesprochen im Rasenfunk. Der kam schon öfter vor. Wie würdest du denn sagen, hat das geklappt, auf Schalke einen Zweitligakader zusammenzustellen?
Ja, sehr gut. Also erstmal stimme ich dir vollkommen zu oder wenn es vielen Zuhörern so geht, dass ich ja selbst sehr viele Spiele auch nicht kannte, gebe ich total offen zu. Ich habe mich auch mit dem Torhüter, der ja nachher noch gekommen ist und jetzt plötzlich auch durch ein bisschen Glück zur Nummer 1 hochgerutscht ist, Martin Freise kannte ich vorher nicht, Thomas Ovejan nicht, Koita Kura, Wout Marcin Kaminski, muss ich jetzt zugeben, kannte ich jetzt auch nicht so wirklich, aber kann man vielleicht noch eher was mit anfangen. Blendi Idrissi kommt aus der eigenen Jugend, also lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Da waren einfach tatsächlich sehr viele Spieler dabei, die neu sind und die ich und ich würde behaupten auch sehr viele andere Schalker gar nicht kannten. Und jeder hat es sicherlich mitbekommen, wie krass der Umbruch bei Schalke im Sommer war. Ich glaube, jeder kennt es, wenn eine Mannschaft absteigt, dann bist du auch teilweise dazu gezwungen, teure Spieler oder gute Spieler abzugeben. Aber bei Schalke war es ja ein beispielloser Umbruch, wie ich finde.
Ganz kurz, um es zu illustrieren, 31 Zugänge, 28 Abgänge.
Und ich glaube, dass nur Malik Csau, tierhaft geschrieben für die, die sich vielleicht fragen, wer das denn ist, der einzige Spieler ist, der in der vergangenen Saison gespielt hat und jetzt auch. Das heißt, alle anderen, die regelmäßig eingesetzt werden, alle anderen zehn, sind einfach komplett neu. Und wenn man sich das vor Augen führt, finde ich es schon beachtlich, dass Schalke natürlich mit den Schwankungen, die es gibt, einigermaßen eine Stabilität schon so flott gefunden hat. Weil, klar, von Schalke erwartet man es oder hat man es vor der Saison erwartet. Aber frag mal bei 14 anderen 2-Liga-Teams nach, wenn die so einen krassen Umbruch hätten vollziehen müssen, ob das dann auch so schnell geklappt hätte. Von daher ziehe ich davor schon den Hut, wie Rufin Schröder das gemeinsam mit auch Gramozis gebastelt hat. Sie haben sehr auf Charaktere geachtet. Das war ja auch so ein Thema für sich auf Schalke in den vergangenen Jahren. Und das ist wirklich jetzt nicht nur so eine Phrase, eine verschworene Einheit, die einfach sehr gut miteinander funktioniert. Das ist sicherlich spielerisch nicht das Gelbe vom Ei. Aber sie haben sich sehr schnell zusammengefunden. Und das war ja auch die einzige Möglichkeit, wenn du tatsächlich, auch wenn es offiziell nie direkt so gesagt wurde, von den Verantwortlichen, von dem einen oder anderen Spieler schon, aber wenn du halt oben mitspielen willst, dann darfst du halt nicht auch zu spät erst anfangen, die Punkte zu sammeln. Bei St. Pauli, wie gesagt, in der vergangenen Saison, wenn du da erst anfängst, in der Rückrunde aufzudrehen, dann ist vielleicht der Zug einfach schon abgefahren. Von daher, vor dem Hintergrund, wie krass der Umbruch aus Schalke war mit all diesen Abgängen und Neuzugängen, finde ich, kann man schon den Hut ziehen, wie Schalke dann unter dem Strich dasteht.
Kirsten, da würde ich gerne dich mit reinholen und so ein bisschen auf das Werder-Segment vorausgreifen. Bei Werder war der Umbruch nicht ganz so krass. 17 Zugänge, 17 Abgänge. Wie, glaubst du denn, steht im Vergleich zu dem, was jetzt Raphael von Schalke erzählt hat, Werder da?
Ich glaube, da ist die Situation relativ ähnlich. Wir haben halt sehr viel die Mannschaft, also aufgefüllt mit sehr, sehr jungen Eigengewächsen. Und das hat man halt am Anfang, Markus Anfang hat am Anfang halt auch echt wirklich die ganze Jugendlichen alle reingeworfen. Und das hast du halt echt gesehen, dass da einfach mega Schwankungen drin waren im Spiel. Also wir hatten ja eine Zeit, da haben wir 3 zu 0 gewonnen und dann 3 zu 0 verloren und dann 3 zu 0 gewonnen. Und das ist passiert halt, wenn man mit relativ vielen jungen Spielern spielt, die tatsächlich ihre erste Saison spielen. Und ich glaube, wir hatten dann teilweise mit dem HSV zusammen den jüngsten Kader überhaupt in der Liga. Eine gewisse Zeit lang. Dann ist Ole Werner gekommen und der hat dann halt erstmal auf Stabilität gesetzt. Und jetzt hat er jetzt wieder so die alten Stammspieler, die er dann aber auch wieder zur Verfügung hatte, weil da waren ja auch welche von verletzt drauf gesetzt. Und da ist dann halt einfach auch jetzt eine gewisse Stabilität entstanden, weil da einfach wieder ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung mit drin ist, in die man dann die jungen Spieler mit einbinden kann. Also, dieses Eingrufen mit einem komplett neuen Kader muss man halt auch üben. Also, ja, wir haben nicht so viel verloren wie Schalke, aber wir haben halt wirklich Schlüsselspieler. Also wir haben wirklich alle unsere Schlüsselspieler verloren.
Daran muss ich eben denken, weil wenn man nur ein bisschen mit dem Fuß in der Werder-Bubble drin hängt, dann sind Transfers, also ich kann mich nur an Hannover 96 erinnern, wo es ein ähnlich fast schon toxisches Thema ist, weil man da eben einfach auch schon so lange erfolglos oder mit mittelmäßigem Erfolg auf dem Transfermarkt agiert. Findest du im Vergleich jetzt mit dem, was der Rufen Schröder bei Schalke gemacht hat, denn das klingt ja alles sehr gut, was Raphael erzählt hat. Kann Werder da mithalten?
Ich denke schon. Ich meine, Schalke und wir sind ja so in einer ähnlichen Situation geldtechnisch.
Also ihr habt beide keins?
Wir haben beide keins. Also bei uns sind jetzt die, die ist zum Glück, weil Frank Baumann im Sommer doch ganz gut gearbeitet hat, auch wenn das einige nicht wahrhaben wollen, ist es der Punktabzug zur Strafe wegen Geldmangels vom Tisch. Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei Schalke ist.
Ja, es ist auch vom Tisch vorerst. Ich will übrigens, wenn ich ganz kurz einhaken darf, Kirsten auch Richtung Max, da muss ich auch Kirsten oder Werder Brehm ein bisschen beiseite springen. Ruben Schröder hat erstmal einen guten Job gemacht, aber es ist auch sehr spannend zu beobachten, wie sich das dann mittelfristig entwickeln wird, weil Schalke auch sehr viel ausgelehnt hat. Ich kenne jetzt leider nicht die Vertragssituation von den ganzen Werder-Spielern, aber es ist halt unfassbar knifflig, wenn du kein Geld hast, hohe Schulden, du steigst ab und du hast trotzdem diese Erwartungshaltung, eine schlagkräftige Mannschaft zusammenstellen zu müssen. Und holst Spieler, wo du eigentlich nicht weißt, wie es dann im Sommer nach die Saison weitergeht, sondern fängst du eventuell wieder von vorne an. Von daher glaube ich, dass Frank Baumann und Ruben Schröder alles andere als eine einfache Zeit jetzt haben.
Also ich glaube, Frank Baumann hat tatsächlich, auch wenn alle meckern, bei Werder schwebt ja seit Jahrzehnten, also eigentlich seit Torsten Frings in Rente gegangen ist, der Wunsch nach dem Wunder-Sechser rum, der endlich geholt werden soll, der aber bis jetzt immer noch nicht gefunden ist. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass wir den im Kader haben, mit Ilya Gruev, einem von unseren jüngeren Spielern. Aber dieser Wunsch nach großen Namen, also sagen wir so die Transferphase im Sommer, was da in Kritik gefallen ist, ist halt einfach scheiße. Die Leute haben gedacht, wir spielen noch Champions League, und wenn Werder sich für einen Spieler entscheidet, kommt er sofort zu Werder. Unsere Realität ist, dass wir zwei, drei ziemlich beschissene Saison davor gespielt haben und in der zweiten Liga spielen und keine Kohle mehr haben, ist bei manchen noch nicht so ganz durchgesickert gewesen. Ich finde, dafür haben wir uns eigentlich sehr gut verstärkt. Wir haben halt wirklich den Vorteil, dass wir tatsächlich nur zwei Spieler ausgeliehen haben, Zwar Lasse May und Roger Asalé, die beide zurzeit auch nicht wirklich irgendwie eine Rolle spielen. Das heißt, die Spieler, die bei uns eine Rolle spielen, sind auch wohl, wenn sie nicht irgendwo bessere Angebote kriegen, kann man mit denen auch weiterhin rechnen für diese nächste Saison. Und wir haben ja auch noch zwei sehr gute Spieler, junge Spieler ausgeliehen, die wir ja auch noch zurückkriegen nächstes Jahr. Von daher ist das auch ziemlich geil. Ich meine, Niklas Beste ist da glaube ich in Regensburg diese Saison der Obergoldgetter. Der kommt zurück im Sommer. Und der Benny Goller ist in Darmstadt. Und den kriegen wir auch zurück.
Das klingt alles viel positiver, als ich das immer so am Rande mitbekommen habe, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, man muss sich auch ein bisschen die Realität angucken. Wir haben keine Kohle. Die Geschichte mit dem Investor ist sowieso so eine Sache. Eigentlich wollen wir ja auch gar keinen. Das heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so demnächst jemand hier Großkohle reinpumpen. Weil wenn in Bremen ein Investor kommen sollte, geht es nur mit Zustimmung der Mitgliederversammlung. Und es wird da solche Einschränkungen geben für den Investor. Da hat kein Investor dran Spaß. Im Endeffekt dürfen sie nur Geld geben und die Klappe halten. Und das macht ja kein Investor so wirklich gerne. Auf lange Sicht haben wir keine Kohle. Und wir müssen aus dem bisschen, was wir haben, was machen. Das Gute ist, dass wir ähnlich wie Schalke, also nicht ganz so geil wie Schalke, weil die Knappenspiele ist das beste Leistungszentrum in Deutschland. Aber auch unser Leistungszentrum produziert ganz gute Spieler. Zumindest für ein Zweitliganiveau immer sehr, sehr robuste, gute Spieler. Dass wir da einfach weiter darauf zurückgreifen müssen. Und das, was wir dazu geholt haben, teils sehr günstig, das macht in der Ergänzung des Kaders einfach richtig Sinn. Das sieht man jetzt auch mit Anthony Jung. Da haben wir einen schönen Verteidiger, der da außen ein bisschen robust und Ruhe reinbringt. Und wenn Nikolaj Rappfit ist, gefällt er mir da eigentlich auch ganz gut im Mittelfeld. Also das ist ganz sinnvoll verstärkt worden für die 2. Liga.
Ja, vielleicht kam da auch ein Teil der Aufregung daher, dass es da ja dann doch einen Unterschied zwischen Werder und Schalke gab. Natürlich auch wegen der Tabellenkonstellation in der 1. Liga. Aber Schalke konnte im Grunde ab, Raphael, Februar, März so etwas für die 2. Liga planen, würde ich sagen, relativ seriös.
Ja, finde ich auch richtig und wichtig, dass du das erwähnst. Also wenn es einen Vorteil gab in dieser grauenvollen Saison von Schalke, dann der, dass Schalke sehr früh wusste, tatsächlich in der 2. Liga zu spielen. Wenn man das Ganze dann nochmal einordnet, finde ich, dann ist es noch viel schwieriger für Werder Bremen gewesen. Und dann erklärt sich vielleicht auch so ein bisschen, dass vielleicht dadurch auch der Umbruch in Bremen, zumindest im Vergleich zu Schalke, aber nicht ganz so riesig ist, weil natürlich auch einfach Zeit fehlte. Vielleicht hätte Frank Baumann gerne noch den einen oder anderen abgegeben und vielleicht hätte er gerne noch den einen oder anderen dazugeholt. Schalke konnte schon sehr, sehr früh schalten und walten. Ob das dann alles gelingt, ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Aber klar, Schalke hatte da auf jeden Fall einen Vorteil dadurch.
Und gleichzeitig war es eben dann bei Werder so, dass auch ich, muss ich sagen, dann die Erwartungsseite, es gibt aber Pläne für die 2. Liga. Die liegen jetzt schon in der Schublade. Da steht dann sowohl der Trainername drauf als auch ein paar Spieler, die man holt. Und ich hatte das Gefühl, wenn ich, ich hoffe, ich erinnere mich da jetzt nicht falsch, Kirsten, aber es hat sich alles ganz schön gezogen im Sommer. Und viele Namen wurden noch genannt. Und dann ist aber gar nicht so viel dann passiert, wie man erwartet hat. Ich glaube, das spielt dann manchmal in so eine Rückmeldung auf Transfers mit rein, obwohl es ja eigentlich mit den Transfers dann gar nicht was zu tun haben muss. Wenn du jetzt nach 18 Spielen in der 2. Liga dir den Kader anguckst, wo liegen denn da die Stärken und Schwächen?
Also, unser Sturm hat sich ja ganz gut eingegruft. Also so diese Doppelspitze Dux Völkruck ist schon ganz schön. Die beiden funktionieren auch super gut zusammen. Also die mögen sich wirklich, das merkt man. Die 6. Position ist halt im Mittelfeld immer so eine Geschichte. Das ist unser Dauerthema bei Werder. Das ist zurzeit halt –wir haben einmal Ilja Gruev, ein sehr, sehr junger Spieler, der seine erste wirkliche Profisaison mit Stammeinsätzen macht. Der zweite Sechser ist Christian Groß, der ist halt schon ein bisschen älter. Der ist ja auch zum Profifußball gekommen, wie die Jungfrau zum Kind. So mit 34 den ersten richtigen Profivertrag zu unterschreiben, ist halt auch eine Sache.
Damals hochgezogen von Florian Kohfeldt, weil man glaube ich keine Innenverteidiger mehr hatte.
Genau. Und das ist halt so, der ist für die 2. Liga einfach echt wirklich super, weil der auch sehr robust spielt, aber manchmal spielt er dann halt echt mega robust. Und dann passieren so Sachen wie gegen den HSV, wo er sich dann sofort eine rote Karte fängt und das ist halt einfach blöd. Wir haben einen sehr jungen Spieler, der spielerisch auch ganz gut veranlagt ist, aber dem halt einfach aufgrund des Alters und der fehlenden Erfahrung die Konstanz fehlt. Und dann haben wir einen alten, erfahrenen Spieler, der aber nicht vom Spielerischen jetzt nicht so begnadet ist, sondern mehr ein Kampfschwein.
Das kann sich natürlich ganz gut ergänzen und gleichzeitig erinnere ich mich, dass ein großes Thema beim Kader Werders immer Geschwindigkeit war und vor allem das Fehlen von Geschwindigkeit, also die Abwesenheit von Geschwindigkeit.
Das haben wir jetzt geklärt.
Aber wodurch habt ihr das geklärt? Durch neue Spieler oder weil die 2. Liga langsamer ist? Oder kommt beides zusammen, man trifft sich in der Mitte?
Ich glaube, da kommt eine ganze Menge zusammen, aber mit Felix Agu haben wir einen extrem schnellen Außenspieler, Außenverteidiger. Der ist ja wirklich richtig schnell, wenn der mal abgeht. Und wer auch sehr schnell ist, der allerdings auch erst seine erste Profi-Saison spielt, weil er ist jetzt 19, glaube ich, ihren Dingshi. Der ist auch relativ schnell unterwegs. Also wenn der jetzt mal so richtig warm wird und der kriegt ja auch immer seine Minuten, dann kann das auch richtig lustig werden mit dem. Also der ist halt auch ziemlich schnell. Leo Bittencourt ist immer ganz gut, der macht das Spiel. Vielleicht ist er nicht so superschnell, aber er macht das Spiel schnell. Also das größte Problem war halt beim Umschalten auch, dass es sehr lange gedauert hat, einfach weil das Thema Rückpass zum Torhüter war, glaube ich, eins meiner größten Probleme in den letzten zwei Jahren. Das Gefühl, das Spiel ist bald im Mittelfeld angekommen, dann ist das Spiel auf einmal langsam gemacht worden und der Ball ist zack zum Torwart zurück und dann haben wir von da wieder angefangen. Und dann ist irgendwie so kein Momentum entstanden. Und irgendwie hat sich das jetzt so ein bisschen, gerade unter Ole Werner jetzt ist auf einmal geht das Umschalten schnell. Ich weiß nicht, wieso es vorher nicht ging, aber auf einmal geht das.
Ja, wir sollten gleich noch über Ole Werner sprechen, aber lass noch kurz den Kader fertig machen. Wie gefällt dir der Abwehr Torhüter?
Also Torhüter haben wir im Weserfunk eine sehr, da sprechen wir nicht mehr drüber, weil Seuve und ich zwei sehr unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu haben. Wir sind auch beide vielleicht ein bisschen zu emotionell verbunden mit unseren Torhüterlieblingen. Aber die Sache ist, wir haben zwei total gute Torhüter. Die haben beide verschiedene Stärken. Wir haben Jiri Pavlenka, von dem wir wissen, das sieht man ja auch und weiß auch glaube ich jeder in Deutschland, dass der auf der Linie wirklich ein super Torhüter ist. Das Problem ist, dass er halt einfach kein guter Fußballer ist, dass seine Abschläge landen regelmäßig im Aus und er macht das Spiel im Aufbau relativ langsam. Er ist halt einfach kein guter Fußballer, das ist so. Und dann haben wir der andere Torhüter ist Michael Zetterer, der vielleicht auf der Linie nicht ganz so geil ist, aber das ist ein richtiger spielender Torhüter, das ist ein richtig guter Fußballer. Der macht die Spieleröffnung schnell und sicher und die Bälle kommen an. Und da musst du dann halt wählen. Und als die Saison angefangen hat, war es dann halt so, da hatten wir auch noch Stefanos Capino, der jetzt bei Bielefeld ist, noch mit im Mix, der halt auch ein starker Torhüter ist. Dann hat sich Jiri Pavlenka verletzt und dann hat Markus Anfang seine Nummer 1 erstmal ausgesucht und das ist auf Michael Zetterer gefallen. Capino ist dann nach Bielefeld gegangen und Pavlenka saß halt erstmal auf der Bank, also teilweise nicht mal auf der Bank, weil er ja Rücken hatte. Und Zetti hat das meiner Ansicht nach auch ganz okay gemacht. Manche haben gesagt, er ist halt manchmal ein bisschen nervös und manche Bälle hätte Pavlenka gehalten, die er nicht gehalten hätte. Da waren aber auch halbe Bälle dabei, die er gehalten hat, die Pavlenka nicht gehalten hätte. Also es ist halt so. Und dann nach dem Paderborn-Spiel, wo wir alle scheiße waren, oder das Spiel da drauf, wo wir auch alle scheiße waren, hat er halt die Torhüter gewechselt, was ich nicht gemacht hätte. Aber er hat halt Pavlenka ins Tor gestellt. Ich glaube, das war so der unnötigste Wechsel in der Mannschaft aller Zeiten, weil es nicht am Torwart lag. In Werder lag es jahrelang nicht am Torwart, dass wir Gegentore kassiert haben. Und die Abwehr ist ein spannendes Konstrukt. Also so, wie wir jetzt die letzten Spiele gespielt haben, habe ich da eigentlich keine Bauchschmerzen mit. Aber dazwischen durch haben wir ja mal richtig ordentlich durchwürfeln müssen wegen Corona oder anderen Verletzungen. Uemma Toprak ist halt, verletzt sich gerne. Das wissen wir alle. Aber wenn er da ist, ist er halt da. Und er ist halt echt eine Bank, der ist ruhig, der kann Spielaufbau. Und der kann vor allen Dingen auch seine Mitspieler, seine jungen Mitspieler um den Ruhm führen, anleiten und denen Sicherheit geben, was ich ganz gut finde. Dann haben wir Milos Velkovic, der meiner Ansicht nach immer vergessen wird und unterschätzt wird. Aber der Typ ist einfach ein echter stabiler Innenverteidiger mit einer sehr, sehr guten Spieleröffnung. Der wird halt immer vergessen, weil er so ruhig ist. Oder weil er nicht so super wirklich spektakuläre Sachen macht. Außer den Scorpion-Kick-Tor jetzt gegen Dings. Das war schon sehr spektakulär. Aber sonst wird der halt gerne vergessen. Und dann haben wir halt Marco Friedl, der kurz in Ungnade gefallen ist, weil er dachte, er wechselt und dann nicht gespielt hat das eine Spiel, weil er sich nicht verletzen wollte. Was ihm wohl seine Berateragentur gesagt hat, die er danach gewechselt hat. Der fühlt sich aber jetzt, glaube ich, wieder ganz wohl in Bremen. Also man sieht ihn die ganze Zeit lachen. Das ist ja immer ein ganz gutes Zeichen. Und der ist halt auch ein sehr, sehr guter Innenverteidiger mit einer schönen Spieleröffnung. Auch zur Zeit einen sehr guten Offensivdrang. Der macht recht gut Tore. Ich glaube, zwei oder drei hat er diese Saison schon gemacht. Also das läuft. Also die Innenverteidigung und die Torhüter, da sind wir eigentlich ziemlich gut aufgestellt.
Ja, so klingt das. Und ich finde es interessant, dass es da auch noch eine Parallele zu Schalke gibt. Raphael, das hast du ja vorhin schon angedeutet. Auch da haben wir einen Torhüterwechsel. Ralf Fehrmann ist eben nicht die Nummer 1, sondern Martin Freise spielt. Wie ist es denn dazu eigentlich gekommen?
Ich musste gerade schon grinsen und hab mir gedacht, Kirsten kann eigentlich weitermachen und das Ganze nochmal erzählen oder dass sie die Namen austauscht. Das Torwart-Thema aus Schalke ist ja schon länger eins, seit Alexander Nybe zum FC Bayern gegangen ist. Und der übrigens damals ja auch Ralf Fehrmann abgelöst hat. Und Ralf Fehrmann ist so wirklich in den vergangenen Jahren so gefühlt die ernste Sau aus Gelsenkirchen. Vor der Saison hatte sich Gramozis tatsächlich auf ihn festgelegt als Nummer 1. Und so sollte er auch in die Saison gehen. Ja, und dann hat das Coronavirus ihn ausgebremst an den ersten beiden Spieltagen. Hatte dann aber ein Anführungsstrichen Glück, durfte sofort im Tor stehen. Und das hat dann aber fünf Spieltage gehalten. Übrigens, bis dahin ist dann Michael Langer eingesprungen. Da war ja Martin Freisel auch noch gar nicht bei Schalke sozusagen. Oder noch nicht lange da, noch nicht lange im Training. Weil er vereinslos war, musste man ihn erstmal noch ein bisschen aufbauen. Ja, und Ralf Fehrmann wurde dann nach dem 1-2 gegen den Karlsruher SC aus dem Tor genommen. Und zwar unter anderem auch genau aus den Gründen, die Kirsten gerade so ein bisschen auch umschrieben hat, bei der Torwartproblematik in Bremen. Ralf Fehrmann ist auch auf der Linie und gerade im 1 gegen 1 und bei 11 Metern überragend. Also da sind ja auch schon viele Erstliga-Stürmer dran verzweifelt, hat aber auch diese spielerischen Defizite. Und da hat schon der Ex-Torwart-Trainer Simon Hensler, der ja jetzt ausgetauscht wurde vor der Saison, mit dran gearbeitet. Und meiner Meinung nach war das ein Fehler, weil man aus Ralf Fehrmann eigentlich jemanden machen wollte, der er einfach nicht ist. Man hat es trotzdem versucht und Graham Mozes wollte halt unbedingt spielerischer noch agieren, gerade von hinten raus und nicht nur die Bälle nach vorne kloppen, was ja grundsätzlich in meinen Augen zumindest ein schöner und guter Ansatz ist. Das hat aber nicht funktioniert, weil –oh Überraschung –Ralf Fehrmann eigentlich noch nie der Typ war, ist jetzt 33. Also meiner Meinung nach wird er es jetzt auch nicht mehr großartig lernen. Und ursprünglich sollte dann eigentlich Michael Langer einspringen. Der hat sich dann nur dummerweise einen Kreuzmann auszugezogen. Der fällt also jetzt noch bis zum Ende der Saison aus, sodass dann tatsächlich Martin Freisel von der Tribüne direkt nicht nur in den Kader, sondern zwischen die Pfosten gerutscht ist. Und das gibt eigentlich wunderbar dieses ganze Torwart-Dilemma auf Schalke wieder. Also der erste Vierschaft ist da wirklich die vergangenen Jahre gnadenlos fortzusetzen mit dieser Thematik. Und dann hat Martin Freisel tatsächlich aber auch einen sehr guten Job gemacht. Ich glaube, das waren diese vier Spiele, die ich vorhin auch einmal erwähnt habe. Die Schalke alle zu Null gewonnen hat. Das waren die vier Spiele, die ersten vier von Martin Freisel. Er hatte auch da die eine oder andere sehr gute Parade bei. Und jetzt schwankt er aber so seit einigen Wochen und hat auch mehr Streuung in seinen Wellen, die er abspielt. Er ist spielerisch definitiv besser als Ralf Fehrmann, ist grundsätzlich auch gut auf der Linie und in der Luft. Letzteres ist wiederum auch ein Problem von Ralf Fehrmann, das Abfangen von Flanken. Also die tun sich da alle nicht sehr viel, meiner Meinung nach. Das sind alles grundsätzlich keine schlechten Torhüter. Ich befürchte nur, dass diese Thematik Schalke auch noch weiter begleiten wird, weil Ralf Fehrmann ja einen sehr langfristigen Vertrag noch hat. Er verzichtet dafür ein bisschen auf Gehalt diese Saison. Dafür wurde der Vertrag dann nochmal verlängert. Und er ist ja so durch und durch Schalke, dass er sicherlich auch nicht so schnell gehen wird, obwohl er ständig Rückschläge einstecken muss.
Ich sehe schon, das ist ein Thema. Ich hatte das noch so grob im Kopf, was da bei Schalke passiert ist, aber dann nicht mehr so genau. Ziemlich irre. Jetzt haben wir aber bei Werder ja ein Thema noch, Kirsten, über das müssen wir unbedingt sprechen. Also wir haben die ganze Markus-Anfang-Kausa im letzten Kurzpass schon mit Daniel Korteus abgehandelt. Da bin ich sehr dankbar, dass wir da jetzt nicht nochmal ins Detail gehen müssen. Und jetzt ist Ole Werner der neue Trainer. Und zumindest kurzfristig sieht es für mich so aus, als sei das das Beste, was Werder passieren hätte können, dass sich der eine Trainer, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, bzw. wir kennen die Gründe, weil er sich einen Impfausweis hat, fälschen lassen, verabschiedet. Und offenbar steht man ja jetzt mit einem Trainer da, der vielleicht sogar besser passt als Markus-Anfang?
Ja, unterschreibe ich so. Ich glaube, Ole Werner war ja auch im Gespräch für die Nachfolge von Florian Kohfeldt. Der wollte aber zu dem Zeitpunkt aus Kiel nicht weg, was fair ist, weil er halt wirklich Kieler durch und durch ist. Das hat jetzt geklappt. Im Endeffekt müssen wir Markus-Anfang dann wahrscheinlich noch für dankbar sein. Aber Ole Werner passt so ein bisschen wie Arsch auf einmal zu Werner. Das ist echt richtig gut. Ich habe da mal so orakelt, er ist so ein bisschen das Beste aus Thomas Schaaf und Florian Kohfeld. Er quatscht nicht so viel wie Florian Kohfeld und macht so richtig schöne norddeutsche Aussagen, wie Thomas Schaaf das immer gemacht hat. Ich warte auch noch auf den Satz Nasser Helm von ihm. Es wird kommen, ich bin mir sicher. Er ist aber auch so ein Fußball- und Taktikverliebter Trainer, ein bisschen so wie Florian Kohfeld, der da auch eigentlich gerne drüber redet, aber er redet nicht so lange und ausführlich drüber, sondern recht kurz und knackig. Und ich glaube, der kommt auch in der Mannschaft gut an. Die scheinen da auch alle irgendwie sehr zufrieden mit zu sein mit der Wahl. Also das ist für uns, glaube ich, ganz gut ausgegangen, diese Anfang-Geschichte.
Aber hat sich denn auch schon, oder was hat sich denn verändert, jetzt dann hin zu Werner, jenseits von den Ergebnissen, die ja jetzt sehr positiv waren?
Also was ich gemerkt habe, ist halt wirklich tatsächlich, dieses schnelle Umschalten geht auf einmal. War mir nicht sicher, ob das erlaubt ist, weil wir das nie gemacht haben. Aber das hat jetzt in den letzten Spielen eigentlich recht gut gepasst. Sie gehen aggressiver ins Pressing, worauf sie einfach Schwächen im Mittelfeld auch einfach mal so ein bisschen überspielen und holen sich den Ball früher. Und ich habe auch den Eindruck, dass das nicht mehr aufgegeben wird. Ole Werner hat es jetzt, glaube ich, aber auch so spielen lassen, wie sie es ganz gerne haben, mit dieser 3er-5er-Ketten-Variante. So spielt die Mannschaft ganz gerne und es sieht alles ganz gut aus. Es scheint auch einen Plan zu haben. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf die Wintervorbereitung, weil ich glaube, dann können wir erst wirklich sehen, wenn die Rückrunde richtig anfängt nächstes Jahr, was wir jetzt davon erwarten, was wir jetzt wirklich erwarten können, weil er dann auch wirklich richtig Zeit hat, sich mal mit allen auseinanderzusetzen und auch Sachen zu ändern. Er wollte jetzt, glaube ich, auch nicht so wirklich viel ändern, weil er einfach auch die Mannschaft nicht so kannte. Im ersten Spiel hat er halt eine Mannschaft mit sehr viel Erfahrung aufs Feld geschickt, die dann zum Glück auch alle fit waren. Das hat er jetzt auch in den letzten beiden Spielen nicht geändert, weil das sehr gut funktioniert hat. Und ich glaube, jetzt wird er in der Winterpause, also in den paar drei Wochen oder wie viel sind das, keine Ahnung, wenn sie dann ins Trainingslager fliegen, wird er sich das, glaube ich, alles nochmal genau angucken. Und dann werden die auch da sehr intensiv an seiner Spielidee arbeiten. Was auch immer das dann sein wird. Aber ich glaube, er ist bei der Spielidee flexibler als Markus Anfang. Der ist ja immer recht starr. Das war ja auch in Darmstadt schon so eine Herausforderung, dass er erst sehr spät seine Spielideen ein bisschen gewechselt hat. Und auf einmal sind die dann ja das letzte halbe Jahr abgegangen, wie Schmitz Katze. Und ich glaube, das war bei uns auch so ein bisschen ein Problem, dass er da relativ starr noch dran festgehalten hat. Und dass dadurch auch diese Schwankungen dann passiert sind.
Mensch, das klingt alles ziemlich gut. Ich habe noch eine Frage an euch beide, bevor wir dann ja auch noch über ein paar andere Vereine sprechen müssen an dieser Stelle. Raphael, du darfst mal anfangen. Was würde denn passieren, wenn Schalke den Aufstieg verpassen würde?
Dann werden Mitarbeiter erstmal aus der Geschäftsstelle gehen, müssen nur noch auf Gehalt verzichten müssen. Dann werden Spieler wie Thomas Auwian und Kio Itakura nicht zu halten sein. Auwian wird dann vielleicht trotzdem gekauft, weil Schalke sich dann einen Mehrwert erhofft durch einen Verkauf wiederum. Offiziell sagte auch Peter Knebel, der Sportvorstand von Schalke, dass die Planung vorsieht, innerhalb der nächsten drei Jahre aufzusteigen. Die Erfahrung zeigt aber –Grüße gehen raus nach Hamburg –dass es ja nicht einfacher wird nach dem ersten Jahr. Ich will damit gar nicht sagen, dass es im ersten Jahr deswegen einfach ist oder einfach her. Aber es wird natürlich dann halt noch schwieriger, weil die finanzielle Situation kennt jeder. Ich glaube auch, jeder, der nicht so viel mit Schalke am Hut hat, ist halt sehr, sehr schwierig. Und da muss man auch schauen, ob zum Beispiel in Simonterode noch viel länger bleibt. Salazar wird auf jeden Fall gekauft. Da bekommt Frankfurt erst nach 2022 eine Rückkaufoption. Aber Churlinov geht definitiv auch zurück nach Stuttgart. Also dann folgt ja an der einen oder anderen Stelle auch der nächste Umbruch. Und dann ist die Frage, wie gut es dann wieder gelingt, alle zusammenzuhalten. Und dann ist auch die Frage, ob es nicht schon wieder einen Trainerwechsel geben wird. Weil der Vertrag von Ramozes läuft halt nur bis Sommer. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass jetzt zu früh, weil Schalke aus den Fehlern der Vergangenheit gelernt hat, unter anderem auch mit den fünf Trainern der vergangenen Saison, mit ihm verlängern wird. Sondern es knallhart wahrscheinlich miteinander verknüpfen wird, ob Schalke Erfolg hat, sprich wieder aussteigen wird. Und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann ist auch der Trainer weg. Und dann bin ich sehr gespannt, wer dann die richtige Lösung sein soll. Weil ich gebe ganz offen zu, Schalke hatte jetzt so viele verschiedene Trainertypen in den vergangenen fünf Jahren, dass ich dann jetzt nicht um die Ecke kommen kann und sagen kann, ja, der ist dann auf jeden Fall der Richtige und mit dem klappt es dann. Also wird dann wahrscheinlich wieder ein kleiner Umbruch erfolgen. Und deswegen bin ich dann skeptisch, dass es im zweiten Jahr eher klappen soll als im ersten.
Kirsten, wie ist es bei Werder?
Also finanziell müssen wir eigentlich aufsteigen. Da geht es uns wie Schalke. Weil sonst wird weiter gespart werden müssen. Ich glaube, so rein von der Mannschaft spielerisch wäre das jetzt für uns nicht so das Riesenproblem noch ein zweites Jahr oder ein drittes Jahr in der zweiten Liga zu verbringen. Weil wir haben eigentlich so gut wie alle aus dem Kader aussortiert also beziehungsweise sind verkauft, die nicht Bock auf 2. Liga hatten. Marco Friedl und Milos Veljkovic, Milos Veljkovic läuft der Vertrag aus zum Ende der Saison. Aber Marco Friedl könnte man dann immer noch verkaufen, das heißt, da gibt es dann halt auch immer nochmal Geld. Jiri Pavlenka wird definitiv gehen, der Vertrag läuft auch aus, der wird auch vermutlich nicht verlängern. Ich glaube aber, dass wir eine ganze Menge Spieler haben, die bleiben würden und wir auch mit jungen Spielern dann auffüllen können, die dann doch ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung haben, was die ganze Sache wieder ein bisschen spannend macht. Aber ich würde es jetzt nicht super als den Super-Gau empfinden, wenn wir jetzt nicht direkt wieder aufsteigen.
Gut, ich meine, wir müssen da ja eh alle spekulieren. Das hat mich jetzt nur interessiert. Ich wollte jetzt gar nicht die Stimmung runterziehen mit dieser Frage. Ich merke schon, jetzt hat diese Sendung auf einmal so eine Schwere gewonnen. Ist ja auch gar nicht so weit. Ich weiß genau, wie wir jetzt wieder gute Laune bekommen, indem wir über den ersten Eftel Nürnberg sprechen. Raphael, die hast du ja unter anderem jetzt dann beim 4-1-Zieg der Schalker und aus Nürnbergersicht logischerweise dann eine 1-4-Niederlage näher beobachtet. Welchen Eindruck macht denn der Klub auf dich?
Ja, schon sehr gut. Ich finde, er ist einmal das Endergebnis ja auch ein bisschen über das tatsächliche Spiel hinweg. Es stand, jetzt weiß ich es nicht mehr ganz genau, bis zur 86. Minute, glaube ich, auf jeden Fall kurz vor Schluss, ja auch nur 2 zu 1 für Schalke. Und ich würde wirklich sagen, dass das Endergebnis dann zwei Tore zu hoch ausfiel. Schalke hat verdient gewonnen, meiner Meinung nach. Übrigens auch dann erst zum zweiten Mal gegen ein Team aus den Top 10. Ansonsten gelang ja nur gegen Paderborn noch ein 1 zu 0-Sieg. Der in Bremen, der wurde dann ja noch genommen sozusagen. Aber ansonsten hat ja Schalke immer ziemlich lange Gesichter machen müssen gegen die Teams von oben. Und das war dann schon, glaube ich, dann auch so ein Statement, weil Nürnberg meiner Meinung nach wirklich auch keinen schlechten Ball spielt. Ich glaube nicht, dass es unter dem Strich reichen wird, um dann tatsächlich ganz am Saisonende noch einen Relegationsplatz mitzuspielen. Aber da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich alle einig, dass wir auch vielleicht nicht gedacht haben, dass Nürnberg eine bislang so gute Rolle spielt in der Saison. Und es hat ja auch ein bisschen gebraucht, bis die Klubberer dann tatsächlich auch ins Laufen gekommen sind. Aber ja, sieht eigentlich alles unter dem Strich tatsächlich nicht schlecht aus. Das hätte auch gut und gerne in die andere Richtung rausgehen können.
Wenn ich mir so angucke, Kirsten, Nürnberg, im Vergleich zu eben den Mitaufstiegskonkurrenten, dann hat man die drittbeste Abwehr. Da teilt man sich aber das positive Schicksal mit dem HSV. Die haben die beste Abwehr. Darmstadt, Zweitbeste, Paderborn, St. Pauli, Schalke sind alle in diesem Bereich. Da sprechen wir von 23, 21 und 20 Toren. Der Unterschied scheint mir dann aber vor allem der Sturm zu sein. Denn da sind alle genannten sehr stark. Über Darmstadt und St. Pauli habe ich schon gesprochen. Jan Regensburg, Schalke 04, Werder sind dann die Nächsten der HSV. Und der 1. FC Nürnberg kommt dann aber erst deutlich später. Er hat erst 27 Tore erzielt, was der größte Unterschied zu sein scheint. Könnte das dann auch daran scheitern? Ist das nur eine Momentaufnahme? Was ist dein Gefühl, wenn du den Club dir anschaust?
Also ich glaube auch, die schießen echt wirklich wenig Tore. Und das ist irgendwo dann, wenn man aufsteigen will, vielleicht ein bisschen hinderlich. Ich habe die eigentlich auch vor der Saison wieder so mehr so im Mittelfeld angesiedelt. Ich glaube auch, dass sie sich da dann zum Ende der Saison hin auch wieder einnisten werden. Weil also, wenn die jetzt nicht irgendwie noch da groß was tun, ist das also mit den Touren, die sie schießen, halt wird es einfach echt schwer.
Also Top-Torjäger sind Zhurunov und Dovidan mit jeweils fünf Treffern. Und genauso war es auch schon, als wir, ich weiß gar nicht vor wie vielen Wochen, mit Flo Zenger über den Club gesprochen haben. Da hat er genau das schon gesagt, dass der Torjäger fehlt. Manuel Schäffler war das ja in der letzten Saison. Und damals war es schon, dass Zhurunov und Dovidan, die jeweils besten Spieler waren, vom Ergebnis her im Sturm. Haben aber halt jeweils fünf Tore gemacht. Das ist halt, scheint mir so, der größte Stolperstein für den FCN zu sein. Also da können wir mal gucken, wie sich das entwickelt. Noch hängt ja der Clubweitiger mit seinen 30 Punkten in dieser dicken Verlangs- und Torjäger. Torjäger kann man ja vielleicht auch manchmal in der Transferperiode zur Rückrunde hin finden. Ich finde, Torjäger integrieren sich manchmal schneller in eine Mannschaft als andere Spieler, die man verpflichtet. Also ja, vielleicht ist da noch was drin für den 1. FC Nürnberg. Wir machen weiter, weil so sehr in die Tiefe können wir jetzt da auch gar nicht gehen, wie es sowieso jede Mannschaft verdient hätte. Wir wollen doch auf Dynamo Dresden blicken. Über die haben wir schon länger nicht mehr hier gesprochen, aber wir haben hier noch ein paar, die im Rasenfunk Kirsten, die liegen auf Platz 11 mit 22 Punkten, haben damit 5 Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz und zuletzt eigentlich ganz gute Partien gemacht von den Ergebnissen her. Also aus den letzten 5 Spielen 3 Siege, 2 Niederlagen. Das heißt, 9 dieser 22 Punkte hat man da sich holen können. Meinem Eindruck nach ist Dresden jetzt auch ein bisschen in der Rolle angekommen, die man ihnen schon vorher zugetraut hat, nämlich als der Aufsteiger, der es schafft, auch mal gegen vermeintliche Favoriten zu gewinnen. Zum Beispiel gegen den KSC zu Hause. Und damit sich dann die Punkte zu holen, die zum Klassenerhalt beitragen.
Ja, denke ich auch. Also ich glaube, Dresden ist auch ohne den jetzt irgendwie zu nahe treten wollen. Eine Mannschaft, die ganz viel über die Euphorie auch auf den Rängen kommt. Die haben ja, also jetzt von der politischen Einstellung mal abgesehen, einen sehr, sehr starken Anhang, der sehr, sehr stark anfeuert und der auch überall mit stark dabei ist. Und ich glaube, die kommen auch viel über diese Euphorie und können dann halt solche Sachen rausrauen, dass sie mal ein Team über sie, die über ihnen stehen, schlagen und sich da die entsprechenden Punkte holen. Da geht halt glaube ich auch sehr viel über den Kampf, der von der Euphorie angefeuert wird. Oh Gott, kling ich dummelig.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, was du meinst. Die Statistik dazu ist, dass Dresden in der F15 seine 22 Punkte zuhause geholt hat. Das stützt dich ja.
Ja, also das ist eine sehr kämpferische Mannschaft. Die hat auch einen ziemlich starken Willen. Und die kommt halt wirklich über die Euphorie. Ich glaube nicht, dass die jetzt über das schöne, spielerische kommt. Die kommen wirklich, die feuern sich über die Euphorie. Und wenn die ein Tor geschossen haben, dann werden die warm. Und dann lassen die auch nicht nach. Also es ist nicht so, wie das auch bei Werder zum Teil ist. Wenn sie dann ein Tor schießen, dass das dann alles läuft. Wir fangen uns dann ja immer noch Gegentore. Also jetzt nicht mehr. Jetzt verlieren wir sowas zum Glück nicht mehr. Also die letzten Spiele. Aber bei Werder ist das dann halt auch so gewesen, wenn wir ein Gegentor gefangen haben oder so. Oder wenn wir ein Tor geschossen haben und ein Gegentor gefangen haben, dass das dann alles auf einmal komplett bei Werder zum Erliegen gekommen ist. Und das habe ich bei Dresden irgendwie so nie den Eindruck. Bei denen habe ich immer wirklich den Eindruck, dass die bis zum Ende kämpfen.
Das ist Dynamo Dresden aus Sicht von Kirsten. Raphael, du hast Dynamo unter anderem erlebt bei einem 0-3 auf Schalke, wo ich jetzt die… Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war Dresden aber auch nicht drei Tore schlechter, oder habe ich das gerade völlig falsch abgespeichert?
Nee, nee, genau. Hast du vollkommen recht. Also Schalke hat sich da auch lange schwer getan. Und Dresden hat da auch sehr mutig gespielt. Und ich kann Markiessen nur zustimmen. Ich finde, dass Dresden einfach –das klingt jetzt auch ein bisschen blöd –dass es schon mehr weiß eigentlich, worauf sie sich einlassen sollten, was sie können und genau auch das umsetzen. Wenn ich das vergleiche mit den Kellerkindern, mit den aktuellen Kellerkindern. Also wenn ich Ingolstadt aure, Sandhausen sehe, sogar Hannover mit dabei. Dresden ist da einfach insgesamt ein bisschen stabiler unterwegs. Sie haben ja richtig stark angefangen. Da hatten sie zwar eine Delle, aber wie du ja auch gerade erwähnt hast, sie sind auch wieder zurückgekommen. Ja, dann gibt es vielleicht mal so Spiele wie 0-3 aus Schalke oder jetzt zuletzt 0-3 in Ingolstadt. Das, glaube ich, zählt dann auch wieder zu diesen Spielen, wo man sich danach an den Kopf fasst und sich denkt, wie konnte das denn jetzt sein, Ingolstadt bis dahin nur einmal gewonnen in 17 Spielen? Und dann gewinnt die da plötzlich so deutlich. Ich sehe das genauso wie Kirsten, leben extrem von der Euphorie, vom Kämpferischen. Aber genau das braucht es ja auch in der 2. Und gerade auch als Aufsteiger. Die Fanszene ist ja berüchtigt dafür. Ich muss auch gestehen, mir war auch ein bisschen von dem Schalke-Spiel da mulmig. Weil die Dresdner Fans –ich glaube, es schimpft sich, das meine ich gar nicht, dass BigTierlich Motto-Tag ausgerufen hatte für dieses eine Spiel. Und da gab es dann sehr, sehr viele Sicherheitsvorkehrungen. Man kennt ja auch viele andere Geschichten aus den Drehungen. Es kann auch sehr stimmungsvoll sein. Und das projiziert sich, glaube ich, total auf die Mannschaft. Und die saugt das aber auch auf und nutzt es tatsächlich. Und dann gibt es im Prinzip Hopp oder Top. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Dresden überhaupt unentschieden gespielt hat. Aber im Prinzip gibt es immer nur Siege oder Niederlagen.
Einmal haben sie unentschieden gespielt.
Ach ja, guck mal. Aber das zeigt ja schon, dass Dresden jetzt auch nicht zu diesen Teams zählt, dass sich irgendwie versteckt oder einigelt. Und so schließt sich der Kreis zu deiner Frage zu dem Schalke-Spiel. So war es nämlich auch nicht aus Schalke. Und ich finde, das kann man dann auch mal anerkennen. Und ich glaube, dass sie sich dann auch unterm Strich deswegen belohnt werden. Ob das jetzt deswegen zu einem souveränen Klassenerhalt reichen wird oder knapp vor dem Relegationsplatz, das sei mal dahingestellt. Aber ich sehe schon, da mindestens drei Teams auch unterm Strich schlechter als Dynamo.
Gehört denn da Hansa Rostock mit dazu, Raphael?
Ja, also zu den Teams, die dann um den Abstieg bangen müssen, meinst du?
Ja, also zu den Teams, die du schlechter als Dresden siehst.
Ja, ich finde schon, das sind keine riesigen Unterschiede. Aber ich habe das Spiel, zumindest jetzt Schalke-Rostock, ich muss jetzt auch gestehen, ob ich über Dresden oder Rostock rede, da kann ich mich immer nur auf entweder das Spiel gegen Schalke oder vielleicht noch ein, zwei weitere beziehen. Deswegen mögen mir die Anhänger es verzeihen, wenn ich das ein oder andere falsch einschätze. Aber rein subjektiv sehe ich Dynamo ein Ticken stabiler und besser auch als Hansa Rostock. Ich würde jetzt behaupten, dass Hannover 96 da noch irgendwie rauskommen wird, ohne weit nach vorne zu preschen in der Tabelle. Aber ich glaube schon, dass Rostock eher Probleme kriegen wird noch als Dynamo Dresden. Ich glaube, dass ganz unten das Feld noch ein bisschen enger zusammenrücken wird. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Ingolstadt und Auer wirklich so schwach weiterschwimmen wie in der Innenrunde.
Bei Rostock, Kirsten, sind, zumindest war das so der Stand, den wir in den letzten Kurzpässen hatten, vor allem die zugelassenen Schüsse, also die Defensive ein Problem. Als wir das letzte Mal aufgenommen haben, waren sie nach den Expected Goals der zugelassenen Chancen letzter in der Liga. Da wird es natürlich schwierig. 31 Gegentreffer in 18 Spielen ist jetzt auch gar nicht so wenig. Aber man hat ja auch drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz, den aktuell Sandhausen hat. Welchen Eindruck macht Rostock auf dich?
Also, ich finde auch, die sind halt... Ich habe jetzt echt nicht so viel Rostock gesehen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber ich glaube, die sind so ein bisschen wie Dresden, nur nicht so ganz euphorisch. Und ich sehe die eigentlich auch, dass die sich da so richtig schön noch in den Abstiegssumpf reinrummeln können. Weil Sandhausen irgendwie schaffen die das ja immer noch, in der letzten Minute sich zu retten, wie auch immer. Für Aue würde ich es mir tatsächlich wünschen, dass sie sich noch irgendwie zu retten. Weil ich möchte jetzt endlich auch mal noch nach Aue. In Goldstadt denke ich, die werden da bub-bye machen. Also die werden vermutlich wieder absteigen. Ich glaube nicht, dass die sich da noch richtig groß rauszummeln werden. Aber ich glaube, Rostock könnte sich richtig schön noch in den Abstiegssumpf reinspielen. Also dafür spielen die halt auch einfach nicht konstant genug.
Ist die Situation der Dresdner nicht so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit der der Bochumer in der ersten Liga? Ich finde, Bochum transportiert das auch total super rüber. Sie spielen jetzt auch nicht die Sterne vom Himmel, wirken aber extrem gefestigt und sehr kämpferisch. Sie spielen glaube ich auch sehr häufig nur Hopp oder Top. Kann man das ein bisschen vergleichen?
Also nach dem, was ich sehe, passt dieser Vergleich aktuell sehr gut, weil auch Bochum jetzt ein paar Spiele gewonnen hat, die man nicht unbedingt gewinnen muss. Auch weil Bochum eine sehr heimstärke Mannschaft ist und seine Punkte wesentlich daholt. Die Vergleiche finde ich nicht so falsch. Gleichzeitig hat man auch ähnliche Probleme beim Ausspielen von Kontern. Aber das sage ich jetzt bei Bochum auf Grundlage von 16 Spielen, die ich gesehen habe. Bei Dresden, zweite Liga, kann ich immer nur mal so reingucken. Deswegen weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich gerade den Dresdnern recht tue. Bei Rostock finde ich noch auffällig, welche Rolle Verhög spielt. Das ist ja was Positives. Zehn Tore hat er gemacht. Das ist, wenn man sich anguckt, dass Rostock insgesamt nur 21 erzielt hat. Ein ordentlicher, erklecklicher Anteil. Also das, was dem Club abgeht, das hat zumindest Hansa aus Rostock. Und etwas, das Ingolstadt ganz lange nicht hatte, haben sie jetzt am allerletzten Spieltag vor Weihnachten noch bekommen. Den ersten Sieg unter dem Trainer Rüdiger Rehm. Und wir haben es ja auch schon angesprochen. Im Dresdenteil 3 zu 0 gegen eben einen direkten Konkurrenten, nämlich Dynamo zu Hause. Damit hat man sieben Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz, zehn Punkte aufs rettende Ufer. Also es ist immer noch ein sehr großer Berg, den Ingolstadt da bezwingen müsste, um in dieser Liga zu bleiben. Aber Kirsten, steht der Sieg jetzt für etwas, was sich da verändert hat? Oder hast du das Gefühl, naja, das war halt so ein Ergebnis, wie es das halt manchmal gibt, dass man dann halt auch mal gewinnt, wenn keiner mehr damit rechnet. Aber im Grunde ist die Saison für Ingolstadt mehr oder weniger jetzt schon auf dritte Liga wieder ausgerichtet?
Also ich glaube, so sollte man ja nie als Fußballverein in die Rückrunde gehen. Aber ich glaube, dass tatsächlich dieser Sieg gegen Dresden zum nächsten Mal ein Ausreißer war, nach oben. Ich glaube, die werden nicht so ausreichend Punkten in der Rückrunde, dass sie da irgendwie noch die Klasse halten können. Weil vor allen Dingen jetzt auch so die Mannschaften, die oben spielen, also die 30 plus oder 29, 28 Punkte haben, sich alle jetzt ein bisschen eingegruft haben. Da gegen eine Überraschung zu machen, wird glaube ich relativ schwer werden in der Rückrunde für Ingolstadt.
Muss insofern vielleicht auch nicht so schlimm sein, weil wir in einer der früheren Ausgaben mal gelernt haben, dass 35 Prozent der Minuten, die gespielt wurden damals, das war der damalige Stand von Spielern, aus der U23 kamen. Und viele aus der 3. Liga sind eben noch mit dabei. Also Ingolstadt ist vielleicht auch ein Drittligist im Gewand eines Zweitligisten, womit man ja auch den Fall eines möglichen Abstiegs dann schon ganz gut mittelfristig abgefangen hat. Denn du hast wenige Spieler dann vermutlich mit dabei, die sagen würden, ich muss jetzt hier unbedingt weg, weil ich habe mir etwas komplett anderes davon versprochen, beim FCI zu spielen. Ja, stimmt, guter Punkt. Nur, dass sie nicht ihre besten Spieler noch abgeben mussten. Das kam bei Fürth noch mit dazu.
Ja gut, das kam bei Fürth dazu. Aber sie haben im Endeffekt eine Zweitligamannschaft in der ersten Liga gespielt.
Gibt es da was zu ergänzen aus deiner Sicht, Raphael?
Ich habe superoffen Punkte, was ich glaube auch, dass Ingolstadt sicherlich noch den einen oder anderen Punkt holen wird. Und auch wenn der Trainer wechselt, jetzt nochmal was anderes bewirkt, wenn ich mich an das Spiel zurückerinnere, auch Schalke, wo Schalke wirklich nicht gut gespielt hat. Das war auch wieder eins dieser Spiele, 3-0 am Ende. Das ist zwar ein bisschen zu hoch ausgefallen, aber was Ingolstadt da gespielt hat, das war schon ziemlich bieder. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das jetzt unter Rehm so viel ändern wird, dass es dann dazu reicht –ich glaube, sieben Punkte Rückstand sind es zumindest auf dem Remigrationsplatz –das einzuholen. Es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass Aue und Sandhausen in der Rückrunde auf dem Schrank schlagen werden und nichts mehr tun werden.
Ich glaube, da haben wir jetzt aber auch nicht so die Neuigkeit für alle Ingolstadt-Fans verkündet. Die werden jetzt nicht gerade vor Schreck ihre T-Tasse fallen gelassen haben. Noch kurz, um zu illustrieren, dieses Dynamo-Dresden-Spiel. Also es war schon wirklich ein besonderes Spiel. In der ersten Minute geht Ingolstadt in Führung durch Antonic. In der 17. Minute schießt Kevin Ehlers ein Eigentor. Dann steht es 0-2 aus Sicht der Dresdner, die fortan und auch schon vorher eigentlich den Ball haben. 72% Ballbesitz hat Dynamo Dresden. Und was haben sie aus diesem 72% Ballbesitz? Dann kreiert fünf Schüsse, davon einer aufs Tor. Also es war offensiv einfach ein Tag zum Vergessen für Dresden. Defensiv hat es Ingolstadt natürlich gut gemacht. Also Henne Ei, Frage, was da den größeren Ausschlag gegeben hat. Und in der 85. Minute gibt es da noch das 3-0. Und dann ist das Ding durch. Also so kam es zu diesem Sieg von Ingolstadt. Und das lässt ja dann auch schon einige Rückschlüsse zu. Auf Spielkultur und so weiter.
Das passt doch dann eigentlich ganz gut auch zu dem, was wir gerade über Dynamo Dresden gesagt haben. Das war dann jetzt ein Ausreißer. Das war einfach wahrscheinlich kein gelungener Tag. Und trotzdem hat man das Gefühl, dann wird halt Dynamo wieder in einem anderen Spiel die Kurve kriegen. Weil es einfach solche Spiele gibt, die haben ja auch andere Teams. Also ich würde jetzt behaupten, 16 oder 17 von den 18 Teams haben mal richtig ins Klo gegriffen. Das fragt man selbst beim Tabellenführer jetzt nach St. Pauli mit dem 0-3 in Kiel. Also ich glaube, es gibt immer wieder solche Tage, dass wir immer noch Bremen und Schalke feststellen in der Rückrunde. Ich bleibe einfach dabei, die Kurve wieder zu kriegen.
Sehr gut, dann lassen wir das als Schlusswort stehen. Es geht am 14. Januar weiter. Die 2. Liga beginnt nach der 1. Liga. Die darf schon früher starten. Das heißt, längere Winterpause nicht nur für die Vereine, sondern auch für euch beide, bei denen ich mich sehr bedanke. Danke, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Ich fand das sehr schön, auch mal die Parallelen zwischen Werder und Schalke zu sehen und dann doch auch die Unterschiede. Vielen, vielen Dank an Kirsten vom Weserfunk. At kirstepinky auf Twitter. Danke dir, Kirsten, dass du mal im Rasenfunk dabei warst. Und ebenfalls großen Dank an Raphael Wiesweg von ruhr24.de. Danke dir, Raphael, für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit in diesem Rasenfunk-Jahr. Es kann sein, dass das hier die letzte Aufnahme des Kalenderjahres 2021 war. Danke für eure Unterstützung, auch finanzieller Art. Der Rasenfunk bleibt paywall-sponsoren- und werbefrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de und ihr unterstützt damit nicht nur uns, sondern auch alle Gäste, die ein kleines Honorar bekommen für ihre Auftritte hier. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die das tun. Vielleicht gibt es ja den einen oder anderen, und die ein oder andere, die das jetzt noch tun möchte. Auch dafür herzlichen Dank. Kommt gut durch die Weihnachtszeit, bleibt gesund. Bitte bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.